interesting when I was trying to think
of a topic today for the lecture for
this one I wanted to show games where
one side is lower rated than his
opponent and he was playing for a draw
and the end playing in meek fashion now
luckily most people in chess yes ah
that's good question I was just going to
say most people in chess they are who
they are
like they don't play really boring one
game and then sack all their piece of
the next game they sort of play the same
so a lot of people when they're paired
up let's say your rating was 1200 and
you were playing in 1800 you would be
relatively pleased if you had a draw
you'd be like I do so many 600 points
higher and as the game goes on even if
you have a winning position you might
think all this is a good time for me to
draw because I'll be losing later not
not the best attitude now why do people
play for a draw that's a human
psychology of chess some people play
chess because they like to play chess
but some people they figure I'm going to
beat people who were worse than me and
lose to people who are better than me
and so to improve on that if I drew
people better than me I would be better
than what I expect and if I do better
than I expect good now that's not the
way to get better at chess but that's a
prevailing opinion of a lot of people so
for example if you played 20 blitz games
with somebody 500 points higher than you
your expected score probably be
something like 2 out of 25 minutes each
quick game yeah so you might expect to
score 2 out of 20 but of course if you
won the first game you might lose the
next 15 and by winning the first game
you might say wow I beat somebody higher
than me as opposed to looking at your
whole life's work of chess what you
should be doing so
one of the problems I have with media
because I have a lot of problems with
them it's not personal media problems
but just in general when I watch
television media team tends to you know
look at one instance of a person's life
and say that's their whole life when
that was like 10 seconds of their life
so maybe like a baseball player is
famous for doing something terrible like
letting the ground ball go through their
legs if they played for Boston right and
then that's not that's not what they
always did that happened on one play but
the media focus is on that
so in chess you know if I play a game
and I lose to an 1800 that's not my
life's work I don't lose 50 games in a
row to 1800 but I did once and when I
was a little kid I lost every game to
1800s because I was a little kid and I
remember being very pleased when I was
1100 and I'd be to 1500 in the last
round that the game actually went into a
chess magazine with annotations I was
like shocked me
wow that's an embarrassment so I don't
want to say now why couldn't you have
asked me that seven years ago oh my
reading is 2562 Wow
sounds good if you had asked me six or
seven years ago it would have been 26 62
now that would have been that would have
been even even I wouldn't have
complained because that's my peak rating
okay so I wanted to show those games and
then I noticed there was one player in
particular whose name I won't mention
because I don't want to embarrass the
guy but if you're spelling it it's obeah
now his name is Dmitry obukhov and
Dmitry obukhov is usually an expert and
occasionally a master so his rating is
between twenty one hundred and twenty to
twenty usually that's 95 percent of the
time okay and he would go on his hands
and knees to draw me I mean it would be
an incredible thing for him
so I've played obukhov many many many
many times because I'm from Michigan and
he's lived in Michigan and we would play
a lot in tournaments I probably played
them between 13 and 16 times and rate
play and he's always trying to draw he's
always trading all the pieces offered me
a draw every move etc now once he won we
got into a drawn position and I ended up
getting a winning position where I was
something like +7 but I messed it up in
time trouble and lost so he actually did
beat me once but the other 13 14 15
games he did not and in fact every game
I'm going to show this lecture is
between me and obukhov where he has the
white pieces and he tries to draw with
Wyatt which is not what she should be
trying to do now if you were here for
the Sinquefield Cup then you'll remember
the last round when Carlson needed to
draw for clear first
and his opponent offered him a draw but
he had a better position so he declined
and he won the game and I had a similar
thing happen except the the loss if I
had been wrong would have been something
like 400 dollars not 30000 I was playing
in the Michigan Open many years ago and
I needed to draw to get clear first and
I had black against a low-rated player
and I moved 15 or 20 he offered me a
drawn equal position but I declined
because I couldn't imagine drawing this
guy it never even occurred to me that he
could draw me and I ended up winning the
game when I declined the draw he laughed
because I got clear first by drawing but
I can't
I could never draw him about 20 years
ago I was playing Angela young who's an
international master in Chicago and the
same thing happened I needed to draw for
clear first and he offered me a draw and
I declined because I couldn't imagine
not winning against him and I of course
I won since then I've lost and drawn to
him but now I can't imagine that I
couldn't imagine it then okay so first
game is the shortest as it should be
every game is between twenty and thirty
moves because he doesn't can't last too
long and I have black at every game and
this was very unusual for me because I
usually don't play this on move too and
I never play this I move three so the
last time I had this position was
probably I mean thirty years ago so I
don't know why I played this line but I
played this guy a lot
I like to play different stuff and I
played the semi Slav which I play with
white a lot but I'd never play with
black and so I've never had this
position with the black pieces and again
any Grandmaster here plays Bishop to d3
or Queen to c2 and then there's a lot of
theory which I don't know any of but I
know how to play with white but blacken
and he played b3 which is very meek and
passive and doesn't go for an advantage
yeah and it's played occasionally but
generally don't want to play b3 with
your knight here probably the nice
better here so it doesn't get attacked
well it has an advantage of me not
knowing it but I wouldn't know the main
line so has no advantage ok this trip to
d6 Bishop to d3 now when my opponent
plays meek and doesn't go for an
advantage usually I go too far I do
crazy things and then I lose okay and
then shear up sends me a note saying
good job okay and so I started doing
that this game Bishop d3 is a normal
move but with b3 that's sort of strange
because into the feeling kind of as
bishop so I play e5 and when you play e5
generally black white wants to give
black an isolated pawn so in this
position
this plant is protected twice by pawns
and once by a piece but now it's all I
protected by one pawn so by capturing on
d5 he would attempt to give me an
isolated pawn in fact every Grand Master
plays this I don't know why he didn't do
that because that makes perfect sense he
took this pawn which helps black out so
I was happy and now my bishop
which was blocked by this pawn is now
free to go and my Knights really nice in
the center so probably blacks already
better here
now one thing this guy likes to do is
trade pieces in trades and trades and
trades and offers a draw while he's
doing it and he likes to offer draws and
trade pieces so it's not clear what
White's should do here but it's clear
he'll trade pieces as he likes to trade
pieces now he doesn't like to blunder
pieces so he didn't do that he played
here and now white is almost losing
already because his Knights not well
defended in fact I see a lot of lower
rated players moving their beep on with
white or black when they haven't castled
yet and they weaken their the weak in
the c3 square and they can get in
trouble which is exactly what happens in
this game I took and when he takes with
the bishop he gives me the e4 square for
my knight and it gives me the f5 square
for my bishop so his bishop is better
here than it is here to stop me from
doing that on the other hand if he takes
with the pawn that his pawn structure is
two isolated pawns and looks sort of
funny probably take you with the puns
better because now I have tactical and
now a disastrous part of the game
occurred
I played Queen a5 and I can't reach a5
so I was a disaster
ok forcing me to move slightly and he
played Queen c2 also a mistake notice
how he's defending his knight and if
you're familiar with the removing the
guard tactic how can we attempt to
remove the guard of the Queen from the
knight grandmaster cracked 94 does
remove the guard unfortunately when we
take it we're pinning the bishop so you
can't play Bishop takes so that would
win but for the wrong person then he
would be lecturing you well you're not
you he's you yeah your jewels
okay so Bishop f5
attacking his queen now my bishop is
protected for two reasons
one is if he takes his knights hanging
and the other is when I take his knight
then my queen can capture his queen so
he really can't take my bishop so he
played Bishop d3
because he likes to trade pieces and
also it's the best move and I saved my
bishop and I attacked his knight again
black has a big initiative considering
have the black pieces when you're white
you should have the initiative not
defend defend defend I hope that you
draw rooks c1 and now since the knight
is pinned and it can't move I have a
fork here I played Knight to be four
forking his Queen in his a pawn and in
fact if I play Knight takes a two that's
not very nice because then I'm attacking
his rook and his knight on c3
so he played Queen to e4 pinning my
bishop and now I'd like to play Knight
to d3 check for King his King in a ruck
but he would take it so I didn't do that
but I unpinned my bishop and I
threatened ninety three check yeah
well that's just two ways to Castle
close right Kings side wouldn't threaten
that because he would take it yeah what
I agree with the questions and what
right well no the bishops defended by
the Queen no no I was saying that I
unpin my bishop and I threatened 93
check castling kingside doesn't threaten
93 check it is hard to do that to get up
still okay yeah so now I'm threatening
93 check at night takes a - I'm not
pinned anymore
he castled I played Knight to d3
attacking all of his pieces and he
played four tricks but as we all know
especially Liam tricks are for kids so
while he's losing because if his rook
moves I take his bishop and his Knights
not sufficiently defended so he played
b4 with total confusion for him so I
took and my knight is protecting my
bishop so I'm not worried about that
he played Queen f5 check but I saw it
was check and he tried to defend all
this with rook here now his idea was if
I play Knight takes bishop my Knights
not protecting my bishop anymore he
could play queen takes bishop so he
thought that was okay however if his
Queen could not take my bishop then I
could take his bishop for free so how
can I kick his queen away from my bishop
yes Liam working a defends my bishop but
doesn't kick his Queen away so he could
save his Bishop with Bishop a1 or some
other move I want him to move his Queen
away from my bishop so I could take that
bishop for free Julian g6 I agree and he
played the craziest move ever now this
guy likes to resign okay and we have
people at the club like that they're
like can I resign yet and I'm like give
me give me one more move so he tries to
draw and then when he realizes he's
going to lose he starts playing crazy so
he can resign early
so well here he's in trouble because if
his Queen moves away from my bishop I'll
take a free bishop so he played crazy
move Knight to d5 which attacks my queen
and now his bishops attacking my bishop
although it doesn't really do anything
about pawn Kings queen but what are you
gonna do so if I take with the pawn for
example pawn takes Knight you would play
Bishop takes Bishop check and my Knights
no longer defend it so he would be
winning Queen takes Knight so he's not
as bad as he plays he's tricky I told
him friend of mine ones that some guy
wasn't as bad as he played and he said
I'm exactly as bad as I play so what's
the winning move for black rook takes d5
and I'm defending my bishop with my rook
which he took I took and then he saved
his queen but he's down a piece so I
saved my rook he attacked my knight but
I saw it and then he's like hey I'm down
a knight so he resigned it sounds a nice
easy win but he played the opening two
passively which he always does he tries
to get an equal position he doesn't try
to get an advantage so by getting by
playing for a draw he's actually playing
for a loss he's trying to get a
reasonable position but he should try to
get an advantage and I should be trying
to equalize because I'm black in fact I
think I do better when I'm black against
him because when I'm white I'm trying to
get an advantage and he's trying to
equalize which is what she's supposed to
be doing but yeah good players resigned
because they're down a lot of material
and they're going to lose for sure and
there's no rule against it so that would
save them time from playing on in a
hopeless position now many years ago I
believe 2006 but I've been wrong before
it's definitely 2006 because I there's a
reason why I know that my wife at the
time was playing in the US championship
why she was playing I don't know but
she's playing and she was rated between
16 and 1800 so she wasn't doing well
she was doing pretty well anyway I told
her she said what do I do and I said
don't resign because she likes to resign
when her opponent was higher rated and
she thought she was losing and I was
like well that's not going to work out
well so don't resign so she got
checkmate at all nine games did not
resign so she followed my advice and see
how she did great oh she was winning a
couple games now another wife before
that she also asked for advice at a
tournament and I said don't resign I
give good advice and she resigned an
equal position and like round four so
one of them listed one didn't but same
outcome okay
d4 d5 that's more like it
this was also played in 2009 and I
played the chigorin the best opening
there is if you're white black I don't
know I always play it with black so okay
and I have more than once you're going
to show you today this gentleman decided
to play this variation which is quite
good threatening the pawn and I've had
this many many many times and the
critical position is here when I take
the knight because why could take with
the pawn or the bishop and they're both
good and I've had this position with
white and black but not at the same time
and this opponent took with the pawn
which is what Kasparov did when he had
this petition against Eve on Chuck and
Kasparov won in less than 30 moves but
he wasn't playing me and I like to play
this move some people put the night here
when I play the trigger I like my
Knights like that and he attacked my
queen but I saw it now this is a
double-edged position it's not boring so
my opponents not going to be very happy
boring players they like symmetrical
positions where there's not a lot of
ideas here there's a lot of ideas
because my opponent has the advantage of
the two bishops and my opponent has a
nice Center
I have a leading development three
pieces to one and my opponent has an
isolated pawn and I have an attack on
the center and my opponent's going to
take a long time to develop his pieces
so there's advantages for both sides
he played d5 and now I played it move
you might find unusual when I was a
higher rated player I would have played
here okay but I rating one down so they
only do that anymore but I still want to
play here because that's a good square
for the knight and the knight can't get
attacked
however the night going there and one
move takes a while
yes question what so I played nine to be
a and my Knights going to go to one of
these squares and then go to c5 which is
what happened he played Queen b3 he's
going to play Bishop to b4 and that's
going to be annoying so I played Knight
a six and now Bishop b4 is not annoying
losses for him and he played Knight f3
I played Bishop to f5 I did yeah that
sounds like something I would do and
well he could take my B pawn and then I
would castle and play Knight c5 later
and have a good compensation for a pawn
but he played a strange move he played a
queen b5 check which I don't get and
then he went back well it doesn't make
sense to me but he's attacking my pawn
but I saw it yes
that's correct but I played Bishop here
and then I went back so I got to retreat
yes both sides are retreating right yeah
so now my pawn is attacked so I saved it
yay he played Bishop e2 I castled and I
assume he castled and I finally decided
not to sacrifice my pawn I defended it
and he played rook in the middle I
defended it again now if he takes he's
in a lot of trouble and he played 91 so
you're right I should have been white
because you got to retreat the knight to
e1 so he wants the night to go to d3 and
defend all these important squares
Knight to c5 bishop before pinning my
Knight a5 Bishop a3 still pinning my
knight and now I play e4 so he can't put
his pieces there and he didn't he played
Queen to d4 a bad move based on a
miscalculation and again this is a good
time to explain why these types of bad
moves are made normally when you watch a
top player game like at the Sinquefield
Cup they maneuver for many moves and you
guys are so tired watch the maneuvering
you go get 2 free food and when you come
back it's the same position and then
when you ring some more and you get more
free food lower rate of players don't
like doing that they're like who if I go
here that might win let's go there
didn't work I can't believe it
so when my opponent play queen d4 he was
expecting Knight f5 attacking his queen
if you moved his Queen back that
wouldn't make much sense but he had a
von calculation ready
he was like whom I'll go here and again
when you take a pin tonight that's not
good because then I can't move but there
was a tactical reason he wanted to win
my pawn so if I take back all in my pawn
and I had calculated if he did this that
I would take his queen he would take my
queen I would take what Chuck he would
play King f1 and we would trade these
pieces and he calculated this and he
thought well I traded a lot of pieces
that's what he likes to do how can I
weigh when there's no pieces on the
board
unfortunately tactically he's losing
because he has what's called a backward
pawned upon on an open line with no
protection and I have a white squared
Bishop which this is a white square and
his King is on the white square so that
all adds up to a victory for me pray
tactically anyway and I played rook F c8
attacking his pawn and he defended his
pawn you Bishop to g4 attacking his King
in Iraq but that would be mean I'm not
that mean no I am kidding so if I played
Bishop g4 what would white do resign
probably yes he would play at three and
then I wouldn't win his rook and then
I'd cry right
so I played rook c8 he played rugby for
and I played it move so shocking that
happy will be shocked now the other half
won't be so let's call on a random
student Lisa Simpson I mean you know I
said you that means him remember what
happened last time okay so I played rook
takes e4 and then if he takes my rook I
play Bishop b5 and get my rook back yay
and he can temporarily defend his rook
with rook c1 but I play rook c8
and then can't defend your rook anymore
so I just want a pawn but
psychologically he was crushed because
when I played rook takes e4 he shook his
head a lot looked unhappy etc etc so he
moved his rook back here because he he
forgot he likes to trade pieces I don't
know he was so upset this should be five
he didn't like the discovered shock so
he played King to d1 rook c8 v1
attacking my bishop but I saw it then he
played f-35 and the game ended in a draw
due to stalemate now he resigned
actually which is terrible to like
resigns that's crazy talk but what's
that
who well you were here for the beginning
you got to watch on the internet and
find out he's 2100 plus tax
occasionally 2200 tons with the taxes
like visa miseries 2200 because players
you're so overrated and you have high
tax 10% at least Michigan 6% and they're
underrated so Pennsbury is you all agree
that their misery players are way
overrated right look at Julien that's
one person should prove my point say I
won't mention that player oh well but
they're two and oh and the Knights so
how do do your do some math okay yeah
your whites position is good except it's
not very good it's actually hard to find
a move for white and this guy likes to
resign so he was very happy to do so
he's like yeah I get to resign it's
actually not clear what he should do
here
this games incredibly bad so assuming
black doesn't have any winning plan I
can still try to win this pot but I
would move my king up and probably here
promote to a queen oh you can't do that
anymore
many years ago you could
right now I'll show you my favorite game
because I played a really cute move and
the annotator of the game who wasn't me
wrote a cute move his he notations I
thought were a bit obtuse okay so I'm
black again and now I played an opening
that's not very popular and nobody knows
the name of it what now that would be
the game Finegold Cara Juana which white
won quite handily Bishop f5 some called
the Estonian defense
some call it the Baltic defence I used
to play in a lot back in the day white
has many moves you that's not a question
that's a chess move anyway let's get
back to the lecture what's that that's a
question
well you interrupted me before I was
going to say Queen b3 is the most
interesting because the main book move
for black here is you incorrect now it's
the most incorrect answer ever yeah
that's I can't get more incorrect
I recommend tomorrow's class at 6
o'clock or 7 o'clock
I got it wrong whichever the beginners
one is you also incorrect by the way
laughing in my moves
F takes e5 you were you were 50% right
because the correct move is e5 that's
that's the book move e5 and I've had
this position before now my opponent
again likes to draw life - trait boring
position so they're not going to play
some crazy line
the most common move is C takes d5 and I
again I've had both sides of that my
opponent played Knight c3 which is
playable and stops bishop takes B 1 e 6
and now C takes d5 is pretty meek time
the games already about equal but he's
going for equal so he was happy fact I
tell you a funny story in 1986 I was
playing Michael Brooks and I won of
course and when the game ended he was
much higher rated than me then and when
the game ended he said why didn't you do
this what gives you the advantage and I
said I wanted I wanted equality boring
that's how I played and he was very
frustrated that's what this guy does
he'd rather have equality than an
advantage because advantage is to try to
win that's not good
equality draw and Jacob knows what I'm
talking about he says he's in that one
there C 6 and this is sort of boring and
we've transposed to a Queen's Gambit
okay now he played III now a quiet the
audience please
now when you develop your queen bishop
which you've probably done I'm not
saying I'm not saying all of you have
done it but most of you have moved your
queen Bishop out right when you do that
this pawn is no longer protected and
sometimes you can punish your opponent
like you know go to your room right now
he'll punish you
so I played Queen to b6 attacking b2 and
it gives them a chance to trade so he
was really happy and he traded right
away before my queen moved away and
stopped a trade
but this trade isn't very good for white
because I've activated my rook without
moving it and I've gotten a pawn towards
the center and most importantly this
point could eventually go to b4 and
that's very distracting the white
there's not really a good square for his
Knight so that was a very bad trade but
he can trade more ninety five and then
when I pinned his Knight more trading
okay it's hard to believe this guy's
higher rated than all of you but he is
and of course I take it was a king
because it's the endgame I want my work
to get out and my King's perfectly safe
if he could he would trade Kings but but
my King so far from his it's hard to do
okay he played f3 okay this is the move
the annotator called cute I agree
find a cute move for black less than
less than 90 degrees right
then you want Ben who rook hg8 rook he8
and you think that's cute you know again
tomorrow seven o'clock there's a class
for you yeah okay so obviously my
opponent just played f3 because you're
paying attention and the reason he
played f3 was to prevent 94 attacking
his pin night but I attacked his pin
night anyway with a cute move yeah rook
a3 I should that's cute isn't it so
taking my rook is risky because it loses
all of your pieces okay and that's
called overloaded his pawn on b2 is
defending the knight and the three
square okay now if you thought that was
cute my opponent played a cute move in
response if we do it six times as a draw
yes well let's let's vote who says it's
cute so they said hey you girl Lee what
you said it was cute well it threatens
to take the knight and then he would
resign so then that would be good
because I would win and he can't take my
rock because he loses all of his pieces
and nobody in the room saw it and so
I'll give him 30 hints so it's cute
right okay you know gets a play move
like that every day every other day now
he played a cute move in response he
castled it looks illegal but it's
Thursday at 7 so now my rook is actually
attacked and he I can't play rook takes
c3 Bishop takes and take his work as his
rooks not there but his Kings not so
safe there so I retreated
because I like retreating now I'm
threatening Bishop takes Knight and rook
takes a - he played g4 but I saw it and
then he played h4 but I saw that too and
then he defended his a pawn in a very
unusual way some would say cute he
played rook h2 and now if I take his
night and he recaptures his work is
defending his a pawn very suspicious
I mean very good threatening the pawn
again and now he blundered which is good
because I was playing him but he's
probably losing anyway he doubled on the
seventh rank who and the idea is if I
take the knight he takes back and he's
defending his pawn but now his knight is
pinned so I played the obvious move take
on a2 and now his knight is pinned so he
could take my rook and then I could
either win by taking his rook or just
taking the night and this Bishop is
quite good because his King is in a lot
of trouble and he did take and I took
and I'm threatening rook a one mate with
advantage and he didn't want to get made
it so he played Bishop to d3 and if I
play rook a 1 he'll play king c2 so I
took with track which way did he take
with the rook and then I played Shaq
what did he do moved out of check and
then I played my last cute move of the
game cute like rook a3 but in a
different way
which of the pawns is the weakest where
I could capture it it can't be defended
by another pawn the f3 pawn cannot be
defended by another pawn so I attacked
it I played a wreck f1 now it's hard to
defend his pawn so he didn't he took but
I took back yes I took back he attacked
by night he attacked my knight again and
now he realized he can't save his F pawn
probably realized it before then he
would be down to pawns and his games not
very good anyway so he did what any of
you would do what would you do now you
would never resign but he resigned for a
draw
well
who do you think's winning whiter black
right doesn't have a color I am very
good there's a famous saying by the weak
player FM Bhogle you love we play for
the World Championship because his
opponent wanted to win so seems like a
good idea
and Bogoliubov said when I'm white I win
because I'm white and when I'm black I
went because I'm Bogoliubov and I have a
very similar saying except I say when
I'm black I lose so if you were here for
the Sinquefield Cup you'll remember even
Cathy Rogers Ian Rogers was the person
who did commentary while standing and
spoke English and yeah and he said
they're going they're flying to Shanghai
from the Netherlands and reporting on
the wood they said we hope it goes all
the way to 10 games because you know as
a boy it's not going to 10 games so I
think they're on a flight right now so
if no tomorrow's the last game they're
going to be sightseeing I don't know I
don't think to rouse me the last game
because how you find has white so she
doesn't win with white okay and the last
game is the shortest and my opponent
played quite badly but there was
something fun at the end this is the
same as I showed you earlier okay and if
you remember the previous game where
this happened white played Knight c3
attacking my Queen which is the main
move here he played Knight f3 and this
just gives white an isolated pawn and
any good player here if they wanted an
isolated pawn would take with a pawn but
my opponent took with a knight because
he likes to trade pieces and there are
some kinds of positions where you don't
want to trade pieces like you have an
isolated
on you want to have a lot of pieces
because you have an outpost so white
wants to put a knight on e5 which I'll
cheat a little bit and then a bishop on
c4 and start attacking but if you play
Knight if you start trading and trading
and trading then your punch is weak so
there was no reason to have an isolated
pawn so black already has an advantage I
saw my Queen was attacked now I see this
a lot and this is one of his worst games
this was actually played in 2003 when he
wasn't yet 2,100 it was a little less I
see this a lot both white bishops and
both black bishops can move freely and
so that's what he should do but he
decided to fianchetto his bishop and
that wastes time because he already
can't move his bishop
he's losing another tempo and it weakens
his Kings side quite a bit so I can try
to punish that with Bishop to g4 and now
I don't know what he should do but he
doesn't my bishop coming in here when he
played g3 he wanted his bishop here so
his bishop was really good his one I
trade his Bishop and is he can't fee so
he played here yeah as king is all
exposed and I checked and now if you
block on he to with anything I get a
free pawn yay so you can't play Queen e2
Bishop e2 or 92 because I take the pawn
for free so he played King f2 just what
white wants to do in the opening no not
really
King f2 I saved my bishop pray and he
went on the attack well your opponent
has three pieces out and you have one
and your King has exposed you should go
on the attack
that'll work okay so that's if he wasn't
already lost he made sure he was now and
I Castle and that pawn is doomed doomed
I don't know what would that was all
about maybe he didn't see I could castle
Queen a4 Knight takes d5 he gets the
trade so he's happy rook takes d5 now he
couldn't play Queen takes a seven but
then I wouldn't do that then I would
probably play queen c5 check Bishop
takes check and then I have all my
pieces out and he has none but that's
what he should do he played here Queen
before and now he should trade Queens
would be a pawn down and lose but he
decided to lose more quickly Queen takes
Bishop e2 and I play queen a3 stopping
Queen aa8 and you know he can't not
trade for so long he has to trade this
is a very easy win for black because I
already have a passed pawn and white
just has no play at all but he made it
seem even easier now of course one of
his issues is his bishops aren't
defended by pawns
generally when you move your bishops out
something's defending them a knight or a
pawn or both here only his King is so I
have a lot of tactical tricks if he
starts taking with his King well he has
to trade because he has to some
compulsion he has so he was pretty happy
traded and he played this terrible move
and I went here now if his bishop moves
I play rookie to check winning more
pawns so he played here and the game
only lasted one more move
he did resign after my next move he
likes to resign he likes to trade so
usually when he's resigning there's not
much left on the board Grand Master
sorry well correct yeah and generally
you don't want to put all your pieces on
dark squares when your opponent has a
dark square Bishop he resigned because
after hear hear
the best he could possibly hope for
would be a pawn down King and pawn
endgame and that's the best after here I
wouldn't take his rook I would move my
king and pawns up on the Queen side and
eventually he would try to get his King
out of the pen somehow and then I would
get a winning a king upon endgame but in
this game he actually played a little
differently than usual he didn't try to
get a symmetrical position but he did
try to trade a lot so this idea of if I
trade all the pieces I can draw that
works out well if your Kramnik are
Carlsen because they know how to trade
they're bad pieces for your good pieces
but in general you should try to win and
then you could win or draw two chances
to not lose and if you just how can I
draw and trade everything then you're
you know you're you're basically just
playing for a loss and all grandmasters
know when you're playing a match and you
need to draw in the last game to win the
match you have to play for a win if you
try to draw you lose and it'll be
terrible so you should always try to win
and Magnus Carlsen showed us that two
days ago and well by the time you watch
this at home he'll be the world champ
now it's up quicker than that right a
little bit yeah
October no okay so he's not the world
champion yet but he will be when you
watch this in a few months